to welcome everybody to the first
presidential h3 podcast sponsored by
honey and quip today our guest is Andrew
yang who is running as the Democratic
presidential candidate did I say that
right yeah yeah yeah good because I
don't want to you know you're running
for to be the candidate it's a whole
thing
if you get my intro wrong then by
Presidential Decree I will not kidding
guys if you hear anything you like here
today with Andrew head on over the yang
2020 dot-com to donate and help support
the campaign I know that you're short on
time we have like an hour hour and a
half something like that so I'm gonna
keep it flowing I'm gonna keep it going
and I want to get this out of the way I
have one thing that I really want to ask
you first is what makes you think you
can be President if you don't even wear
a tie well I didn't wear a tie in the
debate I don't wear a tie in the trail
very much I think America is ready for a
different kind of president who's more
about substance than form mm-hmm and you
know we're not wearing a tie sort of an
emblem of the fact that I'm not a
politician I'm not someone who's been
rattling around Washington for years or
decades and unfortunately most Americans
don't think that career politicians are
going to solve our problems it's one
reason I'm running for president mmm so
what make that's a great answer by the
way it is a conscious choice not to wear
the tie yeah I mean I've worn a tie in
the past yeah you know I don't enjoy it
I actually went to a snooty awful I hate
the tie it's not great I went to uh yeah
prep school as a kid that had you wear a
tie all the time too so that does not
let's say engender positive you have no
experience in holding political office
you went straight from being a CEO right
to running for president does it make
sense that you went straight like it
makes sense maybe to become a mayor or
governor or senator first why did you
decide to go straight to the presidency
the main reason is that I'm running to
try and solve the biggest
problems of our time and I think those
problems are accelerating and getting
more and more serious
so I genuinely didn't think I had five
to ten years of climbing the ladder to
wait to address some of these problems
to me the reason why Donald Trump's our
president is that we automated away four
million manufacturing jobs in Michigan
Ohio Pennsylvania Wisconsin Missouri and
those automation trends are just picking
up steam as we close thirty percent of
America stores and malls because of
Amazon self-driving cars and trucks are
around the corner and driving and trucks
the most common job in 29 states so if i
bided my time and was like oh i'm gonna
run for mayor and then maybe eventually
i'll start trying to make this case it's
like we just don't have time for that
[ __ ] truthfully I didn't have time for
that [ __ ] the country doesn't have time
for that [ __ ] and so decided to run for
president out of the gate and one of the
things I say to people is look I'm not
some [ __ ] who says like I'm gonna run
the government like a business because
they're very very different things you
need very different leadership skills
and it's a different operating model
I've been the CEO of a business and when
you're the CEO if you tell someone to do
something they kind of have to do it
because you're their boss and you're
paying them and if they don't do it then
you'll probably end up making a change
but it government you can't pull that
off you can't be like hey you know Mitch
McConnell I'll do what I say or you know
like he doesn't care it's like you know
they've got a different set of
motivations so you have to do something
that's much closer to what I did as the
head of a non-profit for the last 7
years but you have a vision and then you
try and galvanize energy and consensus
around that vision and that's something
I can do and I'll be very glad to do it
as our president mmm so you see you see
us running out of time and in certain
things and you felt compelled from
urgency to to run for president
is there something it was there a
specific moment where I mean that seems
like a quite a change in career path
where you were like I'm a CEO now I know
you made an exit from that company is
that right when it's sold yeah and I I
was the CEO of a private company that
was acquired a while ago and I started a
non-profit in 2011 I was actually just
talking to some people last night about
the fact that the real divergence for me
was starting this nonprofit called
venture for America
helped train hundreds of entrepreneurs
to create thousands of jobs in Detroit
Cleveland New Orleans Birmingham place
I'd never been honestly like I'd been
operating mostly on the East Coast and
so when I made that decision I found my
excuse me I found myself in all of these
environments I'd never been in before
and I realized just how fundamental the
economic changes were and then when you
do that work for a number of years and
you realize that you're pouring water
into a bathtub it has a giant hole
ripped in the bottom and the hole in the
bathtub threatens to destroy our
political system our way of life over
time that's the urgency you're talking
about right I'm also a parent I know
congratulations to you both ah yes thank
you
joining the parent club and when you
have kids you also have a different
perspective where you think okay how am
I going to leave the country or the
world in a condition that I'd be proud
to leave to my kids and right now I'm
not excited about the world we're
leaving to our kids and you have to yeah
I have two boys six and three one of
whom is autistic and so looking up and
being honest about what I see coming
down the pike I knew that someone needed
to do something and as an entrepreneur
and you know this if you say oh someone
else will take care of this that almost
never works because no one ill take care
of it so I decided I could make a
contribution interesting you say and I
and I agree with you that the reason
Trump was elected is is is mainly due to
the fact that we're actually losing jobs
leaking out to automation but I think
the people that voted for him are not
necessarily aware of that they see there
they are talking about immigration and
they're talking about China and stuff
like this how do you how do you convince
these people who have been kind of being
fed propaganda for so long that that the
issue isn't immigrants or China or
whatever else
it's that are their jobs are being
automated away because an another issue
I see is you know conservatives are tend
to be or
contend to be the party of like anti
give outs right anti-welfare so how do
we convince conservatives that the
problem is not what they think and and
also how do we convince them to be okay
taking these handouts when that it seems
like this is kind of like a naughty word
and in conservative circles well I'm
happy to say that when I presented this
case to literally thousands of Americans
around the country a light bulb goes off
were you saying look it's technology and
automation I'll describe my
conversations with truck drivers two
years ago if you said hey trucks are
gonna start driving themselves in a
number of years they would look at you
and say there is no way a robot could
ever do my job and then that turned this
past year and now the conversation is we
have to make robot trucks illegal very
very different convert that huh and when
you go to people and say look it's not
immigrants it's technology I have never
had any group of people stand up and say
it's not robots it's immigrants as soon
as you say it's not immigrants it's
almost like oh yeah that's right this
kind of waiting for you to say it but I
wanted true I feel like I've experienced
it myself when I heard you talk when you
were on the Rogan podcast it's all of a
sudden click to me like oh thank you
it's oh it's right here it's already
happening oh it's out and then too like
all they do is look up like they see the
grocery stores with the self-checkout
they see the fast-food with like the
screens to touch they see the airports
that used to have clerks and now they
don't so they can see it all and someone
you pointed out to them they say oh yeah
that's right to the second point you say
look conservatives don't like quantum
quote handouts there's one state that's
had a dividend for almost 40 years and
it's Alaska it's a deep red Republican
state is a Republican governor it's one
reason why we named this the freedom
dividend is because it tested better
with conservatives with the word freedom
in it but it's also a dividend on our
shared progress as a country and I had
someone in the Midwest say like as soon
as you made me think wait a minute
companies do this for their shareholders
at the time we can do this so this is
not really
left or right thing it's bipartisan what
conservatives hate is they hate giant
bureaucracies making people's decisions
for them but they don't mind the idea of
people getting economic independence and
autonomy to do what they want
particularly if it seems fair like it
doesn't Alaska so I I'm very curious
actually about if we have case studies
about such a thing of a universal basic
income being enacted I know of her of
her Alaska mention are there other
places that you know of that that have
such a thing yeah there are a number of
incident incidences around the world
there are middle eastern countries that
are just distributing an oil dividend
it's like Alaska revved up some of the
Scandinavian countries have almost the
equivalent in terms of how robust their
social safety nets are Indian tribes
have something similar where they end up
because with casino wealth they start
giving it out to everyone so what is the
effect on the society in which these
happen I think Arab countries is a
little bit of an outlier so strange
situation there but like in Alaska for
example how much how much money do they
get for example and what is the
rationale for giving it out there just
to get people to want to live in Alaska
so it was almost 40 years ago and we're
public in government I realized they had
tons of oil in the ground they're gonna
make some money and so he went to the
Alaskan people and said who would you
rather get the money the government or
you the people of Alaska said us like oh
I thought you'd say that so then that
has grown over time to the point where
now everyone in Alaska gets between one
and two thousand dollars a year no
questions asked and this is a man woman
or child so if you're a family of four
you're gonna get let's call it $8,000
mhm and that's significant yeah
absolutely so this program in Alaska has
created thousands of jobs has improved
children's health and nutrition it's
wildly popular it's decreased income
inequality and it stood the test of time
through all of these years and now
decades so this is an example of
something and if you ask someone in
Alaska whether they like it they love it
it's like the favorite thing that our
governments a majority of Alaskans who
absolutely hate taxes
said they would accept higher taxes if
it meant keeping the dividend and they
liked the dividend so so Alaska's got
the oil
what is mainland America have they can
pay first of all more they you say they
get a thousand dollars a year so you're
proposing the universal basic income the
freedom dividend $1,000 a month for
everyone 18 and older right they have
oil we have marijuana now I'm kidding we
have technology yeah technology is the
oil of the 21st century and we have a
lung musk we have you on monster of Jeff
Bezos for aniline right still even
post-divorce I think is richest man
alive still yeah so ever the best of
luck by the way I was so fascinated by
just by the fact of the divorce his his
ex-wife became like the third richest
woman in the world
god bless that's amazing anyway sorry
so Amazon's this trillion-dollar tech
company closing 30% of our stores and
malls and paying zero in taxes and
that's not unusual they regularly pay
zero in taxes that's this I always hear
that I mean I've been hearing that stat
for so long I feel like we became pretty
successful and the more we made we pay
more you pay we go we go oh my god am i
counting I'm like hey what's going on
I'm paying 50% taxes I thought I was
supposed to be paying like zero and he
laughs at me and says oh well that's
just four billion that's like God all
companies that have fleets of
accountants lawyers yup so I've I've
been in the same boat I ran a private
company and we also paid forty to fifty
percent in taxes quite regularly and so
then you look up and you say how the
heck is Amazon paying zero in taxes yeah
I can explain it
most of these tech companies are
multinationals so what they do is they
move their profits and often their
revenue to markets that have lower tax
rates you know one high haven that
everyone uses Ireland somehow all the
money is going through Ireland so what
does that mean practically okay how do
you operate a business chiefly in
America and then somehow what does
Ireland have to do with you not paying
tax
or the Amazon not paying taxes yeah so
Amazon so amazon has businesses all over
the world and so they can shift revenue
and expenses through different divisions
the other thing is that but they can say
our company in Ireland made a trillion
dollars or whatever or less people are
and and you know our government is so
dark it's just like all good yeah go to
the IRS and be like yeah I ducted uh all
of my mommy I didn't make any money this
year they're like cool another trick
they use which doesn't work for
companies like ours but it works my
Amazon you can expense stock
compensation of various types so what
they do is they look alright the other
thing they can expense is they can
expense various future regarding
investments so Amazon will look up and
they'll literally look up and say oh it
looks like we're gonna we're gonna make
some money this year that's unacceptable
let's take that extra a couple hundred
million or billion or whatnot and plow
it into this new division so they bite
which yeah they can write or they can
just say let's pay our executives a ton
in stock options and guess what that's
something that's an expense
oh my god and so and it makes us rich to
like score so they look at it and there
are different ways they can get the tax
down is located you know because it just
seems so stupidly simple and I've been
hearing this for what seems like my
whole life yet how is it possible that
nobody has been able to to get taxes
from these huge companies well that's
what we need to change and so when
people look around and it's a DP because
I've been hearing that like my whole
life I mean what's different about you a
lot of it is that I'm not owned by any
corporate masters we have a hundred
sixty thousand plus donors and the
average donation our campaigns only $26
so I joke our fans in the yang gang
Thank You yang Yang are even cheaper
than Bernie's fan so I don't owe any
lobbyists any you know backroom favor is
that it it's just lobbying a lot of its
lobbying and then the other thing you
have Congress people who are being
lobbied corporate money has completely
overrun our politics you know there are
a few in the
pending legislators but in this
legislative body of hundreds of bond
sold by just later is like you know you
have a few people Washington DC choose
up and spits out idealists it does it's
a total mess have you spending time
there it's a disaster so there's a
pretty obvious fix to this and the fix
is what other countries around the world
figured out decades ago which is to have
a system that doesn't revolve around
Amazon paying out a share of profits but
instead that hasn't pay a value-added
tax so you take a tiny toll and we've
all experienced this when we go abroad
there's a vet and it's like oxygen it
all works right and so Amazon Amazon
said hey we didn't make any money this
year we'd be like we don't care like you
pay a whole lot everything same every
Google server saying the MacBook ad well
that's one reason why what my plan is to
take that money and then some and just
return it to American consumers
immediately in the form of a dividend
increases the purchasing power of 94% of
Americans is a game-changer for families
and children and women minorities so in
a vacuum if you just passed a VAT we
would successfully get the money from
the Amazon's of the world but our prices
would go up this much then if you take
that money and say look just put it back
into consumers hands and then some then
you increase our buying power and then
it creates a virtuous cycle because
right now if we got that money and we
know Jeff and Amazon would get some of
it back because we'd buy some extra
stuff on Amazon but that's fine after we
get that money and it ends up I'm
confused about I guess what the VAT is
because in Europe when I see of that
aren't I as the consumer it's like a
sales tax that I pay right yeah or is it
the Amazon payment because I I'm in a
depression that it would be me that
would be paying it and not costing
Amazon anything so the VAT goes through
every business interaction and so it is
technically Amazon paying in and in some
businesses you've seen passing along to
consumers in various ways but if it's a
business to business transaction it's
still getting paid I see so it's not
something that shows up on my receipt
when I buy something from Amazon
theoretically speaking you know it would
depend upon the choice Amazon makes
they want to show it to you or not is
the main thing yeah but it out but if
you look at these future trends you have
artificial intelligence coming online
that's going to end up replacing
hundreds of thousands of drivers and
call center workers and right now the
American public is going to get
essentially zero of this value because
again the beneficiaries of the biggest
tech companies they pay zero or next to
zero in taxes so as they soak up more
and more value we're looking around
being like what's going on where the
money go where the jobs so this is why
you need a mechanism so that we all
share in that progress or else things
are just gonna get darker and darker
yeah
so how much money do we need to suck is
there enough money in Amazon and
Microsoft and Google is there enough
money there just to to suck up to pay
this freedom dividend I mean how much
money do we need first of all to to
tackle this there is enough money
especially over time the cost savings
around automating truck driving as one
example are estimated to be a hundred
sixty eight billion dollars a year just
from that one industry so if you
extrapolate it over multiple industries
and then you project over time what
artificial intelligence is going to be
able to do that's really the trap we're
in that right now as that value takes
off if we're in position to see zero of
it then we're just left behind yes but
if we get a sliver of it a sliver of a
very very large number is also a very
very large number so even with the
freedom dividend let's say because
you're saying it's a small even just a
small slice are we moving more and more
to a world where we have five companies
that own everything that are almost as
equal to in terms of its power and and
resources as the federal government as
they soak up more and more more and more
money automate less costs less paying
out do you see a world where these
corporate entities are almost an equal
footing as the federal government and
and is that is that just inevitable
that's certainly the way things are
going right now
and if you were to ask Jeff Bezos uh in
private whether he thinks he's more
powerful than president United States he
probably sure got a bigger house than he
does I'm making spaceships to Mars and
my side job I mean that is what he's
doing
yes it's his side hustle no Mars so
we're already there in essence right I
mean the top companies are running
around our government like our
government is a bunch of clumsy children
and if you look at the recent hearings
you see most government legislators have
very limited notions of what technology
is or can do right and so currently our
most powerful CEOs just see government
of something to walk around and just a
voice mm-hmm
now that that's the world we live in now
it's one reason why people have this
sense of foreboding because they're like
oh man like DC doesn't have its act
together there's something wrong I think
a lot of people sense oh there's
something wrong what is it but the
politics to me and I think to most
people is like how do you even
understand what's going on like people
who say they understand I don't even
believe because there's so much moving
parts there's so much backroom deals you
know so much corruption so much how do
you even know what is actually going I
don't even know I don't even bother to
try that's a very rational decision that
one of the stats I saw was that 25
percent of Americans are quote unquote
politically disengaged right yeah I
think it's a waste of time I think it's
that because what do you get your
information from I mean the newspaper
what's the best source I mean okay
you're gonna read the newspaper you're
gonna watch the news and if they'll so
filtered and removed and even the
debates like you pointed out it just
feel like you're watching a reality and
not actual and not even a good one I
mean they ask you call
questions and expect you to answer in
like 30 seconds and then they cut you
off and they focus so much on the drama
it's like they want it they want you to
get into an argument with Joe Budden
yeah and you know one thing I'll share
with you all is that some of the
campaigns are in touch with the TV
network ahead of time to talk about what
sort of attack they want to the stage
they like an attack on by and around yes
this question would be would play really
well oh yes the campaign says hey we're
gonna make this attack against Biden and
in the network I was okay like we get it
and then they help create that
opportunity what a nightmare I mean what
a farce yeah it's it's quite a disaster
and I want to share with you the
perspectives like I'm I think like a lay
person who happens to find himself on
the presidential debate stage being like
what the hell about this conference call
what are you what are you what's your
message to people like me and most most
and a growing number of people who just
feel disengaged because it feels just
impossible to actually understand what's
going on even when you invest your time
you still don't understand what's going
on so what do we do first whatever sense
of unease you have is probably the least
of it like things are worse and shittier
than even most people believe in my
experience like the the institutions are
just so corrupt and weak and the people
involved are just so checked out and
jaded Washington DC is not a great place
I have friends who've worked on Capitol
Hill and they went in with the best of
intentions and then 10 years later
they're just totally defeated Wow like
it's it's not a good look so first I
just want to verify everyone's sense of
despair like this bear is well-founded
now as to what we can do about it it's
going to take a campaign like mine
that's an outsider campaign a
non-politician completely funded by the
people 26 bucks a pop actually shaking
things up and saying look we can do
things differ
and after I become president we can
transform the right now like the
polarization and the gridlock because
everyone senses that I'm non-ideological
I'm just trying to solve the problems
I'm just trying to do it for the people
and then hopefully we can change the
culture now it's a very tall order it's
gonna be very very difficult but I think
we can do it if enough of us get
together and say look we're sick and
tired of politics as usual and we're
willing to take a chance on the Asian
man who wants to give everyone money
mm-hmm I feel like also with the way
that you are running it's pointing out
at least to me the feeling that I get is
how most of us really can agree on a lot
of things no matter on which side you
are and I think that's what what its
gonna take because you need to be able
to convince people voted for Trump and
pointing out that there's so much wrong
that we can we all need for all of us is
the way for me to do it and I see it
with the way you were running you know
I'm happy to say I'm one of only two
candidates along with Bernie Sanders
that over ten percent of Trump voters
said they would vote for and so with
that that's enough to win I have I
become the nominee I win this election
I think so actually I can't vote but I
would vote you might be able to by the
time the president maybe yeah
that's the way it happens I really I
love America and I feel like it's such a
shame what's going on here and someone
needs to fix it urgently plus you have a
child now an American and all this rage
all the gun the gun violence
I can't take it anymore I really I
cannot hear about it like lately there
were kids that died babies mm-hmm I
can't even imagine if I was the parent
how do you even handled that yeah it's
it's disastrous I mean I as a parent too
I see the images and it's like you know
I mean thankfully my kids are too young
to understand right we have to protect
them from and then change the reality on
the ground
or you know my kids and yours we become
old enough to show up to schools where
they're having shooter drills which a
lot of schools have now let's touch on
that when we come back from a break
we'll be back right after this short
break
we've got Andrew yang yang 2020 calm
yang hashtag Aang
we'll be right back a few short minutes
Eva I would like to tell you about honey
it's a plug-in for your browser that is
gonna save you money all the time it's
free it's easy to install two clicks and
you will not want to spend any time on
the internet without it let me give you
an example here we were looking on
Amazon for a video card look at this the
one that Amazon shows you is 250 the one
that that Hani found is fulfilled by
Amazon and it's twenty seven dollars
less and it ships faster that's right
two days instead of three to five are
you freaking kidding me
not only that honey doesn't just work on
the Amazon it works all over the place
I'm talking about eBay Walmart Newegg
everywhere it works everywhere
it automatically scours the internet for
the best coupon codes available and
automatically applies them at checkout
they have got over 1 billion codes
tested last year and have applied a
hundred and eighty a hundred and
eighty-five million working codes that's
a frickin ass load of savings that
happens seamlessly for free there's a
reason it's got over a hundred thousand
five star reviews and ten million people
who already saving with honey here's
what you're gonna have to do guys it's
there's no reason not to install it it's
free it's easy to use and you can
install it in just two clicks so never
overthink the promo code again get honey
for free at join honeycomb slash h3
that's join honey dot-com slash h3 you
are gonna be saving and you never have
to worry about those coupon codes again
right ela that's right that's right
Ethan yes let me tell you about this
toothbrush right wait right which is our
sponsor quip is a great toothbrush yes
it's got soft bristles I agree it
vibrates for a total of two minutes
which is what you should be brushing for
at least and it pulsates every 30
seconds to tell you to move on
Wow well you're saying that it times out
a perfect 2-minute brush and then turns
off when you're done exactly and then
every 30 seconds it pulsates to let you
know to switch to a different part
section of your mouth you got it what it
looks slick does as if Apple made it
right but it's quick and what else
dentists do recommend it they do are a
lot of them apparently 25,000 dental
professionals recommend it so that's
pretty serious and you it only starts at
$25 that is reasonable considering how
much I high electric toothbrushes cost
you look at these these other big boy
that's right I mean what did this cost
$500,000 $100 dollars and they're bulky
they are that's just one vibrating tube
so you could go to get quick comm /h 3
you get your first refill pack for free
which is this cute little thing it's the
head and a little toothpaste
that's your first refill pack free at GE
tqu IP comm / H Street Wow give it up
for you everybody again get your ass
over to get quip comm / h3 wonderful
yang gang mount up we're back I want to
talk about gun control and then circle
back to the ubi because I feel like I
want I want to talk about that a lot
more but you guys were touching on
before the break the amount of shootings
were having it's at 250 just this year
and you know when I was a kid
prepping for for an active shooter on
campus was not even something that we
ever considered or thought about and now
kids are it seems like mo I mean seems
like all schools how are having drills
having consideration for if there's an
active shooter on their campus and
that's just that's just so beyond wrong
it's just so beyond reasonable I want to
ask you first of all why why do you
think all these mass shootings are
happening to begin with to me it's such
a multi-faceted problem from top to
bottom and so the things that we're
focused on right now are in some ways
that most immediate problems which is
our political rhetoric and climate has
demonized and vilified people on the
other side then makes it seem like
somehow violence might be appropriate in
some circumstance certainly the fact
that we have so many guns in this
country where at almost 400 million
firearms almost one for every man woman
and child
now that gun ownership is concentrated
in the hands of a relatively small
number of Americans one of the stats I
saw was that three percent of Americans
owned 50 percent of the guns so that's
like a lot of guns per person and that 3
percent but 3 percent in a country our
size is still 10 million Americans you
have the fact that the NRA is making it
impossible to pass any reasonable gun
safety laws even though the vast
majority of Americans support background
checks and red flag laws and and obvious
safety measures and then the deeper
problems are around this real this loss
of any kind of sense of purpose or like
the direction
where unfortunately it makes people more
subject to hateful ideologies that can
spread much more virulent ly on the
internet now than they could have even
12 15 years ago finding they're finding
communities that reinforce their beliefs
yeah this internet pioneer named Jaron
Lanier pointed out that negative ideas
and sentiments spread much more
powerfully on the internet than positive
ones if you think about your own
experience in social media it's kind of
true it's like the toxic things like to
sort of take on a life of their own and
so that's helping fuel this set of
problems so that there are problems up
and down and we have to try and attack
each one and turn
but unfortunately going to be with us
for a long time because again we're
talking about a country with 300 million
plus firearms mm-hmm yeah it's it's dark
I mean even if we passed some of these
gun safety laws which we 100% should and
will we need to have a perpetual buyback
in effect in my opinion where we just
say look I'm gonna sell your gun like
we'll buy it off you like that because
we need to try and get the supply down
over time you Stan why are people
feeling so purpose purposeless so
nihilistic I mean really that's what
these people are is just such a dark
nihilistic I mean it always ends with
them killing themselves they want to
kill themselves they want to kill other
people what is that a symptom of in
terms of like mentally where that comes
from I think unfortunately we're in like
a period of just vast disillusionment in
our society where if you keep of age in
another era they would say hey you're
the things that are porn and if you do
this then it's gonna work out for you in
this way in that way and then now we
just don't believe any of it right you
know now you say hey you go to college
part of you is like well just gonna load
me up with debt I'm gonna graduate and
I'm gonna have the job no delts it'd be
like oh you should still do this you
know like whereas before maybe that
promise actually was real maybe you went
to college that things would work out in
very positive ways so I hope people look
around and say I don't believe in our
institutions I don't believe in what my
future holds and then you become subject
all sorts of very terrible and sinister
ideas and ideologies I mean I could
speak for myself as a college graduate
that without I mean the very unlikely
chance of me succeeding as an
entertainer before that I was really I
was a waiter I had no prospect of
finding a serious job I lived in Israel
for five years with ela and I was able
to find a job there because I was
qualified as a English speaker but I
think that the prospects are bleak for a
lot of people there's just not
opportunities out there yeah the numbers
bear it out too
I mean our economy has stopped producing
quality jobs and benefits for years and
years when 94 percent of the new jobs
that are getting created are temp gig or
contractor jobs that often don't have
secure benefits and so if that's what
you're producing in your economy then
people rightfully feel like their
futures often quite bleak so let's say
we get the freedom dividend going and
we're giving everyone a thousand dollars
a month yeah I should I should get into
that but I'll finish this thought and
we'll get into it but like if we're
giving people $1,000 a month is that
gonna solve that issue even you know I'm
like and if we keep going into the
future 50 years there 100 years yep
I mean how many jobs are left right well
this is the fundamental reinvention
that's in many ways at the heart of my
campaign so right now our economy
revolves around these ideas of capital
efficiency where the market says you
know if you're an accountant you're
worth 75 thousand driver you're worth
46,000 mm-hmm and when I'm saying right
now is look technologies and they come
that's going to do the job of the
account and the truck driver and then
what is there a new market worth going
to be not what it was you know like it's
sort of unclear what the new value is so
we're in the midst of the greatest
economic transformation in human history
and we need to start finding new
pursuits and jobs and ways to value our
own
and one of the examples I use that my
wife is at home with our two boys one of
whom has autism and the market values
her work at zero and their millions of
women around the country in the same
boat where we're like your your times
were zero and we all hope we all know
that the work she's doing is some of the
hardest and most important worth anyone
yeah you know you have a two-month-old
you're like holy crap is the hard that's
dead that's a hard with capitalism
though right because they don't produce
met like tangible I guess tanda but they
don't they don't write produce to the to
the economy in a touchable way right
it's a variable asset and so in a way we
have to transform what we think of as
tangible value so if you make another
human being stronger and healthier
that's good immensely valuable yeah it's
just right now our economic statistics
don't value that appropriately or
investing in your and having a happy
healthy family is good for society yes
and so this is the great opportunity in
an age where technology is going to end
up assuming more and more work is that
we have to rethink and broaden what we
think of as work and then we have to
come up with different and better and
more human ways of valuing our own time
because if we play out the capital
efficiency race we lose an epic level
you know I I joke but it's true I was an
unhappy corporate attorney for five
whole months and I can guarantee you can
automate that job away like this is it
just like the warehouse shelter like
this is the lawyers the accountants the
radiologists like it just goes on the
list so that so we have to take this
chance to evolve and start thinking more
deeply about ok what is the work we want
to do what is valuable in our lives how
do we reward and incentivize the work
that we need more of for ourselves and
so I have some big ideas on this the
thousand dollars a month is not the
solution it's a foundation it's like the
floor on which you can start building
but it gives us a chance it gets the
boot off of people's throats and it
gives us a chance to start measuring our
economic progress in things that would
actually matter to us like our health
and
being our mental health and freedom from
substance abuse how our kids are doing
how clean our air and water is like
whether we enjoy the work we're doing
the things that might actually get us
excited one of the days currently seem
like a privilege you know to someone
who's just busy surviving yes but one of
the jokes I tell us how many people get
excited about GDP when they wake up in
the morning oh my god I'm gonna make a
big contribution so if you were to say
how many of you get excited if you were
to make your community stronger mentally
healthier people would be like oh that
would be tremendous it's just most
people don't have the opportunity to do
that kind of work so this is the big
chance we have and we have to take it
because if we stay on this road too long
GDP and capital efficients are going to
send us flying off a cliff and one of
the things I say to people's like look
self-driving trucks will be great for
GDP you're gonna save tens of billions
of dollars it's gonna be terrible for
the three and a half million truck
drivers and the seven million Americans
who work in truck stops and hotels and
diners around the country waiting for
the truckers to get out and have a meal
so you guys run a business and so you
have measurements you look at all the
time it's around like how engaged the
viewers are like huh like how many
people are clicking on things we need
the right measurements for our society
we made up GDP almost 100 years ago and
even the inventor said this is a
terrible measurement of national
well-being and we should never use it as
that a hundred years ago and so here we
are just still following it a hundred
years later being like Oh GDP is gonna
tell us how we're doing we need to
evolve mm-hmm do you have an idea for
what that new metric might look like I
mean what what what is it yes I do so I
call it the American scorecard and it
keeps GDP as one data point but it
integrates health and life expectancy
mental health and freedom from substance
abuse childhood education and success
rates environmental equality and we have
numbers for these things and so we can
integrate them into our economic
measurements and then at the State of
the Union every year as president I will
actually present the scorecard and say
as an example eight Americans are dying
of drug overdoses every hour that's
terrible and unconscionable so we're
going to get that down by 50
over the next few years and here's how
we're gonna do it and then if
individuals or companies or
organizations put resources to work to
move society in that direction then they
actually get rewarded economically
because right now the problem is that
all the economic rewards cut in this
direction and then all the helping
people rewards cut the other direction
right so what went in it sense of look
like for let's say Amazon - how could
Amazon contribute for example to an
issue like that well the first thing we
do is we take our fair share of every
Amazon sound distribute it to people and
that's not something Amazon has a choice
about yes like hey guess what this is
the new way right and then the and I
will say I'm supported by hundreds of
techies who are down with this plan
because they're not all bad they're just
like look I'm doing my job and like I
get that there are these problems so I
wanna quit the VAT that you put on
Amazon theoretically what percentage are
we talking about of their revenue well I
my proposal is a 10% VAT which is half
the European level oh wow sorry go ahead
I never got that that stat I'm just
curious so essentially 10% of all the
sales Amazon's making goes is becomes a
tax to the government
yeah no pretty low in this game if
you're looking at 10% 10% yes so so
that's the first movies you say look
guess what American people now get a
slice it'll help you to everyone's happy
and I have hundreds of techies who are
behind me and think that this is the
best path forward I think Jeff Bezos
will be down with that or they'll lobby
against it well I know that Jeff Bezos
knows that his number one obstacle now
is the US government and so he has to
figure out how to manage that it is no
mystery he bought the Washington Post he
moved Amazon's HQ to mostly to the DC
area
he bought this giant home there he gets
it he's like okay the number one thing
that could stand in my way of getting to
do whatever I want is the is the federal
government waking up and so let me try
and keep at it back to sleep it's almost
unimaginable that one human being could
not could be so powerful
but also so hell-bent on unsynced early
affecting the economy for for his own
benefit for I mean how could you as one
human it's almost inconceivable isn't it
to get inside his head and to think I
mean just to just to keep gathering and
gaining for for oneself at the benefit
of an entire country does he must not
see it that way surely oh he doesn't see
it that way I mean he's spending
billions on rockets to Mars and for him
he thinks the wealth is much better in
my hands than the government's hand
because I'm going to advance the species
I'm gonna get us to Mars what the hell
would the government do with this money
the government would just do something
stupid with it so that's one perspective
it's his perspective you know we can't
take that perspective way to the back if
we're the American people and then it's
not just Jeff it's like you know the
Jeff of Industry why's he like there's a
lot of Jeff's yeah there are a lot of
Jeff's yeah yeah so so the number one
big move is we say look we get a slice
and that's going to make society
stronger and healthier but number two if
they do something cuz right now big
companies they do something for good PR
and then they say to people look it was
good PR so what we say to them is hey
Amazon if you can demonstrate then
you're making children in this community
strong or improving the mental health of
this group of people or helping these
ex-convicts reintegrate into society or
cleaning up the environment and we can
document that then we can give you a tax
credit for that and so my tax credits
zero well I know in this case so
obviously we'd get them off the zero tax
right you know and they could carry over
the tax credit I mean there are
different ways to create carrots and
sticks for these companies the trick
right now though is to try and align
their well-being with ours because right
now their bottom line is like goal one
two and three and then they're paying
zero taxes also part of their job one of
the things I say is look it's Amazon's
job to try and pay as little in taxes as
possible it's our job to make it it make
it impossible for them to pay zero in
taxes I went over the game is rigged
right now they don't
a strong competitor they don't have a
certain competitor yeah we were talking
about gun control we got we got off that
really really quickly somehow but I did
want to ask you this to circle back to
that it's it's a complicated issue you
say that most Americans want
common-sense gun laws it does seem like
a party issue where most conservatives
there's kind of this echo chamber of
people who are saying don't restrict us
the government wants to take all of our
guns I mean there's propaganda but but
how do you how do you get around the
Second Amendment like the wording of it
specifically says the right of the
people to keep and bear arms shall not
be infringed do you intended that the
authors of that meant for there to be no
restrictions on it at all because it
does say shall not be infringed so how
do you interpret that line well to me
you have to think of the intent at the
time and at that moment they could not
foresee automatic weapons that could
kill dozens of Americans and very very
short periods of time for them bear arms
meant you know a single-shot musket or
rifle to make sure that you know that
like you you can't be completely
marginalized in you know own town or in
your own country so I'm for adhering to
the Second Amendment the sense that
there are many many law-abiding gun
owning Americans and they have that
right and their rights going to continue
mm-hmm yeah they're they're strong
propaganda because what you always see
is people basically saying they want to
take all of our guns away yeah that that
is the argument and that to me is
because if you look at the numbers
eighty to ninety percent of Americans on
both sides the I'll agree that we should
have a background checks for gun owners
they agree that we should not have
people who are criminally violent or
have some other red flag associated with
their record be allowed to buy guns
the vast majority of Americans on both
sides al but you're right that there's a
passion in subgroup and it goes back to
what I said before 3% of Americans own
50% of guns right I have a feeling
that's a very passionate 3% what I
wonder too is when this was written
we're citizens allowed to out cannons or
other you know weaponry of
more massive destruction do you know
what I'm saying I do know what you're
saying and I don't know the answer to
that uh and and today ii mean this is
morphed in a particular way because of
the purpose is to defend yourself
against government incursion i mean at
this point like our government owns
thing is bigger in cannons you're and
any ak-47 or whatever you've got me the
government if they want your that's not
gonna make a difference yeah and and so
that this is like a to me something that
has strayed from the original of the
framework yeah okay and one joke that
joe rogan said is that if the writers
the constitution woke up today they'd be
shocked that we didn't write any new
[ __ ] right you know like the
constitution actually had ways to be
sort of uh you know like modified i mean
the whole point was that it was I mean
it was meant to be a living document
it's meant to be yeah yeah and and
that's one of the dangers right now in
the u.s. is that we have lost confidence
our government we've also lost
confidence in our government to update
its own operating system right where one
of the things I point out is how the
heck are we still hyperventilating about
Supreme Court justices who are 80
something years old like oh my gosh they
get sick like it's gonna be terrible
it's like why do we all why do we have
lifetime appointments for Supreme Court
justices like you know because when they
started that back in the day one people
do not live as long as they did now so
you didn't have six year old yeah yeah
and number two Supreme Court justices
just stepped down for any of a number of
reasons they didn't just stay there
until they died it wasn't like some some
political like long game no and they
gracefully step down step down yeah and
and so we just need to try and
solve the problems of this time with the
tools we have in this time and the tools
we have are much more advanced in some
ways like around our economic
measurements like we actually have
measurements that we can utilize that
are much more nuanced and powerful than
GDP as an example do you think that
video games make people violent I should
say that I was a gamer growing up so I
think I understand gaming would you play
Warcraft Starcraft that generation
that's my shed
brood war yes Starcraft the first
expansion set yeah aircraft I was a
Protoss guy yeah you would be yeah so
you so I think that gaming culture
speaks to some very natural and
important instincts among men in
particular think men are the majority of
gamers I think that there's a lot of
community involved I remember making
friends online and everything no there
are certainly some games that probably
make you a little more numb to certain
forms of interactions than others but
the majority of gaming cultures in my
experience is quite benign so you're
saying there are certain pockets where
you think could desensitize people to
for example violence yeah I think if
someone were just to play first-person
shooters like all day every day for a
while you know they might become like
you know like a little bit checked out
as to what it means to be holding like a
firearm in real life and like well you
know the actual impact in the real world
of what that would mean but that to me
would be like an edge case that would
apply to like virtually none of the
gamers that I actually know in real life
when I see your point about like if
you're playing a first-person shooter
and you go to a gun range to shoot a
rifle obviously you're going to find out
that what you're experiencing the video
game is not very realistic when you see
how heavy it is and the amount of
kickback it has and out loud it is but
what giucose would you would you support
the claim that a lot of these people who
have been doing these mass shootings who
have played first-person shooters all
day or is is that actual and observable
because I well that this is something
that you see in the media Fox News for
example and the president recently said
that violent video games are part of the
issue contributing to this amount of
mass shooters so that's what I'm getting
at specifically to me that would be very
very very low on any list below many of
the more concrete elements like how they
get their hands on an actual gun would
be like at the top of the list and we
really you know like rhetoric that
villainized other people or NRA taking
our freaking legislature hostage like
those to me would be the top of the list
and then somewhere after you get through
dozens and dozens of other things like
what would be like some impact of video
games mm-hmm that's fair enough that's
fair answer and very true I mean I was
quite shocked to see the president come
out in his speech addressing these these
back-to-back shootings we had and and
and and specifically saying violent
video games are part part to blame or
one of the issues that we need to
address to prevent this from happening
in the future well that that's in many
ways a political answer because it's
trying to say look the things that are
up here on the list I don't want to talk
about watch it so let me pick out
something that's lower on the list and
elevated it kind of speaks to people
that don't really understand to because
I saw it on Fox News the day before and
it speaks to people like my parents who
have never held a controller in their
life and can easily digest that oh yeah
kids are playing violent video games so
they're shooting up schools but at any
rate speaking of Trump if you're on the
debate stage one on one verse Trump he
has a very specific debating style as
everyone knows of almost the
you know the cadence of a high school
bully the name-calling the degrading but
he's very fierce debater and and very
successful debate or two and think the
creates quite a spectacle do you have a
strategy going one-on-one if you were to
get the Democratic nominee
how would you confront Trump on a one in
one debate a trump voter in the Midwest
said to me that he can't wait for me to
debate Donald Trump because he thinks
that I would crush him and the reason
why he said this is that whereas Donald
Trump's all bluster and spectacle you're
all facts and logic I'm like ice to his
fire right and so one of the the jokes I
was trying to imitate Trump and I was
like you know comrade yang go back to
China or something like that and then
yeah that's what we came up with as his
nickname for me because it's like a
little racist and the socialist thing
right and why I say you know in other
context is like it's not socialism it's
capitalism where income doesn't start at
zero but in a debate with Trump it would
just seem so ridiculous because I would
just be there talking the facts saying
look here the real problems and some of
the problems he called out and you got a
lot of credit for that but I have real
solutions and people can pick up on that
very very quickly where he's like we're
gonna bring the jobs back we're gonna
build a wall it's like I'm gonna
distribute bounty yeah and give you
$1,000
yeah month and I agree the problems are
real the Democrats response in the last
cycle he was like we're gonna bring the
jobs going to build a wall trying to
make America great again
and then the Democratic response was
America is already great right and that
is not what I'm saying
I'm saying we have we have real problems
and we need to solve them as fast as
possible and one way to do it is by
giving people a dividend of a thousand
bucks a month to be a game changer for
millions of families so people can see
through the bluster and even a lot of
people who voted for Donald Trump are
tired of it
mm-hmm absolutely what do you what do
you think the Democrats big problem was
against Trump I know you you touched on
one issue of them kind of saying hey the
status quo is actually
is what they're saying and as for the
words that you're most people know
that's just it's like well why do I feel
this way then but what what why how is
it possible that Hilary lost Donald
Trump I mean it seems unimaginable it
seemed unimaginable at the time what
were the fatal flaws of her campaign
that you that you saw it was a
relatively low number of swing voters in
the swing states Michigan Ohio Wisconsin
Pennsylvania you had only 65 thousand
people in those states vote the other
way and then Donald Trump is not our
president there was almost certainly
some degree of interference and it's
been documented that the Russian
government has been trying to push our
elections in particular ways and I have
a lot of bots that are you know
elevating certain types of online
discussion so there are a bunch of
factors but to me the one thing the
Democratic Party should be examining is
why does so many Americans also not have
much faith in the Democratic solutions
mm-hmm no and that's something that we
can fix we can say look if the American
people aren't buying this set of
solutions and proposals like maybe we
need to translate into something that'll
actually touch people day to day that
trusts people because one danger that
Democrats get into is that they trust
institutions more than people yeah you
know it's like how are we gonna fix
things we're gonna you know fix this
institution or we're gonna send everyone
to college we're gonna do these things
and and then it's like well some of that
will help some people but more Americans
would be excited about it if you put
your confidence in them and you acted
like we are all owners and shareholders
of this democracy like small D Democrat
okay let's let's get to the heart of
your campaign the universal basic income
the freedom dividend as you call it you
say it tested better with Republicans
with the word for you did you do I don't
know what is that you did actual like
test like focus groups yeah well it was
market sampling and online so we tested
a bunch of names Social Security for all
universe
basic income obviously opportunity
dividend prosperity dividend freedom
dividend was the clear winner
it's a beautiful American phrase I could
see like the flag waving in the wind and
the bald eagle screaming the freedom
dividend can you explain what universal
basic income is for those people who
don't know yeah universal basic income
is a policy where everyone in a society
in this case every US citizen gets a
certain amount of money to meet your
basic needs no questions asked
so my proposal of freedom dividend would
be a thousand dollars a month in the
hands of every American adult starting
at age eighteen until the day you die
twelve thousand dollars a year and this
seems dramatic but there's actually been
proposed and almost passed in America
any number of times over the years
Thomas Paine was forward at the founding
of the country Martin Luther King was
fighting for it 1967 when he was
assassinated in 1968 Milton Friedman and
a thousand economists endorsed it in the
70s it passed the US House of
Representatives in the Congress twice in
71 so it came this close you know what
was the amount they were they were
prepared to give out then it was about
twelve thousand dollars a head well yeah
and they even ran studies if you can
imagine a government that was so
functional that they actually just
started giving money to Americans just
to see what would happen the US
government did that the successor giving
people money betting on what's going on
and the data was very very promising
they did that there they did that what
they do
they picked random groups of Americans
in New Jersey and Colorado and other
parts of country to start giving them
cash and then following around to see
what happened really yeah I mean this
was like a lottery this was all the rage
in the sense that everyone thought this
was a good idea again a thousand
economists signed a study saying this
would be great for America if we just
guaranteed a certain amount of money for
every American we just passed Social
Security we just passed Medicare and so
the American people were looking around
being like hey like maybe we can do some
other great stuff
and Martin Luther King was saying like
we should do this and then it was
endorsed by a lot of people and then it
passed US House of Representatives
so during that time Congress when they
were looking to pass it they said what
we should just give people money to see
what happens and you said the results
were good the results were really good
you know what happened so it passed the
US House of Representatives twice and
then it got stalled in the Senate
because Democrats in the Senate wanted
an even higher income threshold I should
you not and someone who worked in
democratic politics at that time said it
was the biggest mistake we ever made
which is and then and then the moment
was lost and Nixon gets impeached and
then you know like err like the pendulum
swings we wind up with Reagan and then
the whole moment was lost but it just
gives you a sense of how mainstream this
idea was how the like it came this close
to being law it became a law in Alaska
and you know like not that long
afterwards in the early 80s and so it's
it's not like a far-out idea and that's
one of the things that frustrates me is
that now you know I'm like the
quote/unquote futurist president okay
being like Oh crazy thousand bucks a
month like this was mainstream American
political wisdom in the 60s and 70s what
the hell happened to us we're now we
think it's nuts like it's like well now
when you didn't even more than we did
that yes now we actually know and and
when you start thinking about it for a
minute like it becomes common sense but
like he gets caricatured in various ways
even though it actually again it's like
a deeply American and mainstream idea
and now like Barack Obama came out and
said we should talk about it
you know Elon Musk and like Zuckerberg
and others are like we should totally do
it like it's it's actually in many ways
this conversation is definitely overdue
in my opinion this should have been
passed years ago certainly an exciting
time or were where your campaign is
growing your people are it's resonating
I mean what an exciting thing it would
be for the United States well yeah
anyone watching this are listening to it
you can become part of the yangyang to
join yeah it's very people
you gave $27 you'd be an above-average
member of the gang think of it as an
investment yeah get $1,000 oh my life
yeah you know what's the return on 27
bucks that I can it's very high how
would you get you just get a wire
transfer every months engine you sign in
you know you you give them the way you
want the money you know direct deposit
account is positive well what about
someone who's making a lot of money is
it a tax reduction or you you it's money
that you put in the account so it comes
in your account
and you don't pay tax on it but you pay
money on your other income just don't be
okay
how'd you get interested in UVI when was
there a moment where you're like this
this is the solution I mean so I ran
this nonprofit that I had started
venture for America that our job was to
create American jobs we helped create
about 3,000 American jobs over seven
years and I got a bunch of medals and
awards and like it wouldn't be like oh
yeah well done so during that time I was
obviously very interested in jobs and
the future of work so I would read
various books about the future of work
and some of the books about the future
of work were like hey guess what robots
are coming and we should really start
looking in and what that's gonna meet
you of work is there's no work yeah
and so a lot of them were saying we
should do a universal basic income and
then I when I read these books I said oh
yeah that makes sense we should totally
do that
bed and then in 2015 I read another book
called raising the floor by a guy named
Andy sterner used to run the biggest
labor union in the US and he said the
future of Labor as no labor were screwed
and we should move to a dividend and so
I read that it was like wow it's not
just the tech guys it's the labor leader
saying we need to do this so I became
convinced at that point and became very
passionate about it during that period
so I think this is a misconception that
a lot of people have or at least an
opinion the intention of universal basic
income is not to enable people not to
work yeah
right I mean because $1,000 a month
first of all not enough money for most
people and and second of all I think
that a lot of people derive purpose in
their life from their work so within
like in 50 years when there's no jobs
and and or let's say let's say ten years
someone can't find a job they're getting
$1,000 a month what do you do when you
wouldn't that's not enough
so first could not agree more that one
of the biggest misconceptions is that
universal basic income where the freedom
dividend is somehow going to reduce work
because number one it recognizes a lot
of the work that we're already doing
that does not get recognized and it
would be an enormous catalyst to
entrepreneurship arts creativity
nurturing care giving all these things
we kind of want to do that the market
says it's not worth enough for you to
make a living at it so don't do it so it
would create and recognize and reward a
lot of the work that we're trying to do
is number one number two if you imagine
what twelve thousand dollars a year
would mean in a town of let's call it a
hundred thousand adults you're talking
about another twelve million dollars
like a month yeah that that's coming
through that town and so that doesn't
just help the individuals that
supercharges the local businesses it
supercharges the local nonprofits it's
supercharges the volunteer organizations
and and so when you say what are the
jobs of the future look like it could be
that twenty years from now it's very
normal to work in and a job that just
helps make other people stronger
healthier mentally healthier helps clean
our environment things that right now
there's no market demand for there could
actually be massive opportunities in the
problem right now is that again we're
following capital efficiency and it says
these things are worth zero right so the
big change we have to make is if we
change the measurements and say these
things are actually worth like a lot
then that's the heaven those are good
jobs right it's just right now those are
not good jobs to have because because
there's no money yeah they pay shitty
and like you know no one respects you
and it's like if you do that just about
you know so that's like the the
evolution we have to make and it's it's
more achievable than people think I mean
the first steps just get some money into
people's hands and the great thing is
you put money into people's hands that's
going to supercharge the kind of work
that people want to do because people
would choose to then start a new
organization start businesses donate to
their local local Lord such an
interesting idea too and I mean there's
such a disparity of wealth not just with
the jeff's of the world but between you
know Kansas and Los Angeles thousand
dollars is gonna help lift them up a lot
more than it is people in Los Angeles
and I think among citizens of the United
States would make a big difference in
equality of wealth as well
it really would the disparities between
different parts of the country are so
vast yeah you travel around at a
different world yeah we're a lot of
little countries or a lot of different
countries in one country yeah
and that was one of my experiences with
venture for America going to many of
these regions I not been to you drive
you know an hour out of Birmingham or
something like that like you find
yourself in like a different sort of
environment right yeah I've seen that
too but I'm wondering we've talked about
the VAT tax does that pay for the whole
thing with this increased taxes on
middle or lower class people it
increases the purchasing power of 94% of
Americans you know you're like one of
the jokes is like why did the bank
robber rob the bank because that's where
the money is we got to go to where the
money is is not it like the heads of
like the average workaday American so
but the the the great thing is here the
other ways we get the money so number
one get a slice of every Amazon sale
every Google your Facebook ad does that
cover the whole thing no but here's the
magic number two money in our hands ends
up growing our economy by ten to twelve
percent and we get 400 billion in new
tax revenue because of all the
additional money's getting spent number
three if you get
the boot off of Americans throats you
end up making us healthier better
educated mentally healthier and one
study said that just alleviating gross
poverty would increase our GDP by 700
billion dollars just based on better
education to health outcomes and that's
it like not more businesses started none
of that is just health and education
mm-hmm and then number four we'd save
hundreds of billions on things like
incarceration homelessness services
emergency room health care we're
spending over a trillion on that stuff
now it's true and there was a
corrections officer in New Hampshire who
said to me flat out he said we should
pay people to stay out of jail because
he sees that when they're in jail we
spend so much money this is a prison
guard making this case to me so if he
sees it we try and say with like oh
we're saving money by not spending money
on ourselves we just end up spending the
money and more expensive in dark and
punitive ways anyway yeah so you
invested in ourselves and the trickle-up
economy then you end up saving yourself
tons of money so in short you are not
raising taxes on middle and lower
classmen oh no
the goal is to get more purchasing power
into our hands because right now the
middle class is getting eroded very very
quickly mm-hmm and that's not where the
money is
you know then we gotta go where the
money is yeah okay so who would be
eligible I know you say anyone over 818
until the day they die for example would
a legal residents like my wife be
eligible what undocumented residents be
eligible illegal immigrants guest
workers so it is only citizens but it's
one reason why having you become a
citizen and be awesome become a citizen
yang gang yeah I'm for a path to
citizenship or people who are here and
undocumented I'm certainly for a path
make it easier for people who want to
live and work here to stay here I'm the
son of immigrants myself right no like I
know that immigrants are very positive
for this country socially economically
but the dividend would kick in after you
become a citizen okay so it's a very
powerful incentive to go through all the
rigmarole and then you're probably
dealing with right now
what about citizens of
that is such an interesting question so
the reality is that the economic
benefits become exponentially higher if
the money gets spent within the country
itself rather than having a large number
of citizens who let's say moves to
another part of the world and then spend
the money there so you're a citizen you
get the dividend forever but there's
like a certain time frame after which
like if you live abroad for a certain
number of months then the dividend gets
like held for you for when you come back
to the interesting so you don't lose it
it's just a cruise yeah interesting
is there any prevention let's say I want
to go live in Thailand cuz it's cheap I
go come back in three years I get all my
dividends and then I bounce back to
Thailand that's like the thing we're
trying to avoid is that then but then if
you bounce back to Thailand then you
know the dividend would start accruing
again so the goal is to make it so that
the vast vast majority of money gets
spent here mm-hmm
yeah whether it be disqualifying factors
felons for example people in prison if
we're spending the money on your
incarceration then you don't receive the
dividend the benefit if you're in jail
yeah I don't get the money but the great
thing then is you come out it's a very
powerful incentive for you to stay out
so felons who have served their time get
the dividend when they come out they
start them out and also does not accrue
during that time does not accrue right
so but then if you come out then
everyone's excited to see you mm-hmm
it's like a thousand bucks you know
imagine like coming out of prison and
everyone's like psyched to have you
because you're coming with a dividend
whereas right now you come back and you
have very unclear prospects yeah yeah
how would a homeless person received
this money you know I just had a
conversation with people about this
obviously the homeless persons not in
position to have a bank account and sign
up and get the money but it creates an
enormous incentive for us to help that
person get on their feet is right now
what's the economic incentive to help
that homeless person zero in many cases
so imagine if you were a city agency or
a non-profit and you said hey every
person I help there's a thousand bucks a
month in it for them and then I'm going
to get some of that and then all of a
sudden you have much more in the way of
resources to help you poor homeless
because Los Angeles isn't in the midst
of a homeless crisis I wonder if
something like this what would make such
a big difference and homelessness
because it's and incentivize them to to
get off the streets and it gives them an
option to live with dignity yes cuz
right now the problem is that again if
you you fall through the cracks near
homeless like our incentives to help you
are very low it's just if you become a
nuisance and even then it falls to our
public agencies and nonprofits and we
know those are vastly under-resourced
and so this would be a game-changer for
the level of incentives necessary to
help get these homeless people off the
street and then maybe even have low-cost
housing available for people over time
because if you have a thousand bucks a
month we're able to get a roof over your
head in many many cases yeah I mean this
is the evolution of our economy to
actually work for us and when I say us I
don't mean like people who are just you
know doing well I mean the people who
are struggling our substance abuse have
problems that are putting them out in
the street yeah I wonder if there's any
unforeseen consequences of the freedom
dividend for example if you're putting a
thousand dollars in everyone's hands how
for example does that affect the house
the housing market you know is there a
situation where the inflation land ends
up moving that money back into the hands
yeah I mean all the sudden when when
when the people who motivation is to
make as much money as possible know that
everyone's walking around with an extra
thousand dollars in their hand what are
the things that we need the most in this
world medicine health care housing food
and and if you look at it those are
three of the biggest sources of
inflation in our economy is housing
education health care because those
markets don't actually function
competitively or dynamically right so so
well how do we prevent these people from
sucking up all that extra money and just
becoming richer so I have separate plans
to address
inflation in health care and education
because those are their own animals
housing is the stickiest because a lot
of it is based upon local zoning regs
and NIMBYism and so even if the
president I can't be like hey guess what
we're gonna like wipe out your zoning
regs like that's not cool
but I will say that if you have a
thousand bucks a month in your hands it
makes it so that if a landlord tries to
really gouge you or stick it to you that
you're going to be able to be much more
portable and then if there are three of
you or four of you'd be like hey instead
of living this landlord stick it to us
the four of us are getting four thousand
bucks a month let's buy that piece of
crap over there turn it around
and because the income is portable it
doesn't necessarily mean you have to
stay within whatever thirty miles of a
particular place of employment or
anything like that so it actually makes
it much more fluid and dynamic again now
to the extent that we can control it we
should try and curb the ability of one
municipalities to not have affordable
housing because again everything is
following up following the dollar and
the society so if I have a choice
between building a fancy high-rise for
yuppies or affordable housing I'm gonna
do the former it's the extent that we
can push incentives towards creating
more diverse affordable housing options
that's the direction we have to go but
it is gonna be harder to stick it to
people if they have portable income I go
everywhere
I want to we're coming towards the end
you're busy busy but it's good I'm glad
you're busy I'm looking forward to
everything else you're doing but I want
I have some kind of abstract futurism
question for you as you are kind of you
know the candidate of the future you
know I call myself a present test it's
just the other politicians are behind
that's a great so we talked about AI
taking jobs but we we're now when we
talk about AI I think we're talking
about automated systems but what I'm
talking about
is self actualized AI art of actual
artificial on television general
intelligence yes it's called whether
with a you know a self of so with a
sense of self-awareness
and self-preservation this is something
that a lot of people think is not in the
you know on the far horizon so we did
with an AI become you have this great
potential and and a great risk I think
for example hey I can crunch the numbers
over in one year can question numbers
over thousands of years to find
unsolvable problems or incurable
diseases yeah but at the same time do
you think that an AI of that magnitude
is proposes any kind of threat to
humanity and civilization I believe that
we should not be overly concerned about
artificial general intelligence just yet
because when I talk to the foremost
researchers in the space they do not see
a path from where we are now to
artificial general intelligence they
don't see that on the horizon no they
don't see the path it would have to be
like a whole series of breakthroughs and
learnings that right now we have machine
learning algorithms that can solve an
incredibly complex problem beyond any
human intelligence but they're
essentially complete idiots and like
two-year-olds at anything that's not
that problem they're dumb like that you
can give them this enormous data set and
they come up with brilliant correlations
and insights but they're not going to
plug in to Skynet and like threaten us
any time soon
what I'm more more concerned about is
dumb artificial intelligence getting rid
of a lot of our jobs which is going to
happen much much faster than the
artificial general intelligence to me
that's a backburner concern I know there
are some very very smart people who
disagree with me on this they're
concerned and they're right that these
trends this development can sometimes
happen in explosively nonlinear ways you
know if I could be even while I having
this conversation there's some I think
the problem is that by the nature of it
that once you do have one breakthrough
then the machine itself it's evolved it
immediately yeah the the folks I talked
to believe we're still a ways away from
a GI
but theoretically I mean theoretically
after you get a rate of self-improvement
then it can go to infinity and then you
can get there very very fast yeah and
are you afraid of that or you are you is
that something that is certainly a tool
for human advancement that's
unparalleled but a risk do you think it
is a risk I mean that there are real
hazards associated with dumb AI I mean
you can use it to cure cancer but you
could also use it to hack someone's
infrastructure and make it inoperable
there are different things that are
possible so one of the things that I say
to the folks and I'm friendly with a lot
of the techies is that I want to be
their partner as president but I also
want to have a technologist who's
representing the public interest who's
in the vicinity who's like hey guys
maybe we should unplug this we have to
think about what a regulation on a and
and this is one of the most fundamental
issues is like if you are a technology
you look up and be like am I really
gonna let this dumb backwards government
try and like regulate let you know that
that seems like a disaster having some
bureaucrat in the room being like don't
do this like like most techies would
like you know want to throw themselves
out a window if that was the situation
it's what is it why you need an actual
technologist that the other
technologists like actually respect
right and like who's just there being
like guys like this is not a good idea
right now like we should actually like
pull back it's a tough balance but it's
one we have to achieve as fast as
possible and the thing I'm excited about
is a lot of the smartest techies in this
space actually are open to it and in
some cases even welcomed it particularly
if the government is willing to put
resources to work to help us stay
competitive with let's call it China
whose plowing billions and billions into
the computing infrastructure necessary
to make their algorithms smarter and
even our richest companies are looking
up saying like I don't know if we have
those kind of resources so that's the
partnership that I'm looking to forge
and I'm friendly with some of the people
that are already at the cutting edge of
that do you think space is a worthwhile
investment I do think space is a
worthwhile investment
kind of sad that we're past the days of
NASA being like you know mission you
know mission to Mars like all the the
60s movies now now all that talents
working for you know SpaceX what's your
argument in favor of exploring space
colonizing Mars or the moon in the face
of such great challenges here on earth
so let me be clear if I had a choice
between fixing our problems here on
earth making it so that we could get get
out of here oh yeah like I would
obviously choose song problems on earth
and just much much higher return there
are many more of us here where it's our
natural habitat I think that space
exploration is a worthy endeavor because
it tends to push the frontier of human
not just knowledge but also capacities
there are many innovations that stem
from us having to try and solve such
advanced technical problems I was trying
to get our people to let's call it Mars
and and being able to live there so to
me most real innovations happen at the
frontier level and so if we can try and
push ourselves in that direction that's
positive but if you look at the order
magnitude of both the problems and the
value generated would be if you have a
choice and you obviously have to try and
let's say fix climate change here on our
earth or keep it so that we're actually
able to feed ourselves in healthier ways
mm-hmm so you know I'm very much like I
can do both so yeah it's like we should
be able to do both but you know it's
like I'm kind of geeky I mean you can't
be like yeah I mean we got a there's
there's some intangible value to the
dream of of us as an exploring species
you know yeah completely yeah but it's
it's interesting that that's moving now
to private companies maybe Elon Musk is
more likely to get to Mars before the
United States government yes
and when I I said before in the sixties
the government was giving out money to
see what happened now it's private
individuals it Sam Altman it's Chris
Hughes his people giving away money
being like what's going
just goes to show that what the
government used to do now is in private
hands and that to me is something that
is not ideal honestly because we should
be able to help ourselves as a society
without relying upon a handful of
private individuals right well I'm
getting red flags backs back in the back
after I'm president we'll do a special
that will not happen interview but I'll
own the White House no no no not you if
you become president you're gonna be way
too busy to talk to my dumb ass I
disagree
I want you to be cover and I actually
think you've got a shot I really do like
you you're you're you're on a trajectory
the last debate you cut through the
[ __ ] masterfully eloquently and I
and I very much look forward to seeing
on that stage again and I think you
really do have a shot because because uh
like AI we're not gonna be saying linear
growth here that's right guys if you
want to support the campaign yank 2020
calm you can donate and think of it as
an investment guys huge returns good
luck on everything and looking forward
to it and pushing you all the best thank
you congratulations
thank you guys for watching appreciate
you god bless we will be back on Friday
yeah for our regular scheduled episode
so have a great week everybody
we'll see you that that's uh my
[Music]
you
[Music]